Last of Us fire HBO to [__]
goats this is exactly up your alley the
whole time
yeah the whole time
yeah I'm like yo Andrew this is the
perfect show for him Army it is gonna be
I think everything the little girl
father son yeah yeah oh no it's not
outside his daughter oh [__] yeah this
the girl that you say look like like
your wife what the lady Marmot who's
that from Game of Thrones I said she
looks like I said she looks I said that
was her character in the show I was like
oh yeah she's like a nurse or whatever
no she's the no [__] Queen who I
thought it was the one that's married to
Jon Snow no there's the girl in it that
you joked look like oh I didn't on the
podcast is that me
yeah but uh but yeah she's a [__]
amazing the girls she's [__] amazing
actress this is incredible but we
haven't seen her really Flex we saw her
flexing Game of Thrones she was a
[__] [__] but you know what this is I
remember Walking Dead Season one you
were super into it but then when it got
to be more about like humans versus
Humans you were out yeah this is just
gonna be that first season of Walking
Dead the whole time but no I I did a
survival element the thing about the Q I
like the I like the human versus Humans
I like the jail shows for that reason I
like what happens when like you know
Society falls apart right and like how
do we recreate the rules and like what
it really is Humanity how do we actually
treat each other when there's you know
no water no food like who are we really
right so I like these types of shows but
um the what I what I thought was
interesting about this was the
recreation of society what do we do when
everything falls apart so that you know
it takes place it starts at least in
Boston it's like okay what has happened
how have they restructured it what's
going on it's fire it is a zombie show
but like even the premise of it is kind
of interesting so so the idea is um the
premise scares you yeah the premise fire
like the beginning is it's in 19 like 78
or some [__] or 63 these two
[__] are talking on TV smoking
cigarettes you can smoke cigarettes back
on TV like scientists and
um they're on a talk show talking to a
talk show host yeah and one guy's like
I'm worried about pandemics and there's
going to be pandemics whatever and now
there's air travel and he's basically
describing covet yeah yeah literally and
then uh and then the other dude goes
yeah I'm not worried about pandemics
like we'll figure out some sort of
immunity for pandemics that's not what
I'm worried about because I'm worried
about fungi and there is why you worry
about fungi he goes well the fungi is
the the real concern I mean do you know
what a fungus will do if it infects you
like what does this with insects all the
time there's certain fungus fun guys
fungi fungi they will go and infect an
insect and then it will use its body as
a host and it will uh it just controls
it's brain make it do certain things
that it wants to do make it eat certain
things they want to eat completely takes
over the insect is like a real thing
yeah this is weird but you've heard
about this yeah yeah we're like parasite
will take over the brain you see like an
inside just like crawling around yeah
and you're like real the fungi they talk
about is a real it's real fungus okay so
then he goes and then uh so they create
the scenario and then the other guy goes
yeah but that's never happened because
there's never been a fungus that's been
able to survive in a human body because
of the human body is over 94 degrees and
there's no way for a fungus to survive
at something 94 degrees and the guy goes
this is a 1973 he goes yes but if the
world were to get warmer for example who
knows how they would have to evolve in
order to survive and then fast forward
and then you see it start to happen and
then blah blah blah but a really cool
plausible scenario yeah right
to get me invested in a zombie type
thing that's not exactly zombie but like
it feels like zombie yeah and now I have
reality everything is based I'm good I'm
ready to go and I'm still running away
from things that are trying to devour me
blue shoes gotcha back okay it has got
your back because Bluetooth same active
ingredients inside Viagra Cialis okay
but this is the one that we rock with
Bluetooth is going to be delivered to
your [__] house for free think
about that all you gotta do is pay five
dollars shipping but they gonna give you
that first month for free bluetooth.com
makes you use the promo code flagrant
and make sure you satisfy the women in
your life the way they deserve to be
satisfied the stiffest the longest The
Bluest bluetooth.com promo code flagrant
now let's get back you know what's crazy
is Avatar they spent I don't know I mean
they made money but they spent like
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars trying to get us to care about
the environment through these movies I
don't care anymore or less but when you
tell me we could turn to zombies the
[__] guys
I've ruined it for myself I really did
it
um but I also
I also watched um some [__] on YouTube
about you watch the whole [__] story
of it yeah I know I almost did it I'm
like now it's like because you want to
know what happens yeah because it's
based on the video game I did that [__]
with the house of dragons uh somebody
posted this clip and they were like uh a
sneak peek of what happens next season
the house of dragons I start watching
that [__] I'm like this feels like real
in depth about this
actually took me right to Game of
Thrones yeah this is the Peak bro that's
not even there's no sneaking it's still
sneaking all
that serious
ly so bad but so I made sure I wouldn't
do this but I [__] up because it shows
you like all the movie parts of the
video game so it's like it's like a
really long story yeah I know the
holster I know it's I'm gonna ruin it
for you too don't do it you will you
[__] will I know it's cool they based
the movie This is the first HBO show
based off a video game oh but they've
done that with movies before like they
did Resident Evil yeah Wreck-It Ralph
Wreck-It Ralph no obviously I've done
video game with Sonic and that kind of
[__] yeah but uh but I remember when
this video game came out and I was like
oh this is if I wasn't if I was 10 years
younger I'm playing this non-stop yeah
like right up my alley I love this
post-apocalypse like what how are humans
gonna survive Resident Evil was kind of
like that and um
yeah it was dude HBO is the goats man
and they're [__] great and they it
seems like they did a good job of
pleasing the video game nerds because
I've read little tweets and they were
like this somebody said this is a one
for one like so far this is exactly what
the video game is that's the easiest it
seems like the most straightforward
thing in the world to do but somehow
Hollywood tends to [__] it up but they
were like nah keep it and they even
showed a shot of the middle when his
daughter yeah like the way he's hugging
her is almost exactly the way the video
came with character hugs yeah in the
video game so when they get infected do
they become zombies
we don't even know how they get infected
what I love about look great I know
how they solve everything but uh but
like yeah what I love about a great TV
or movie is that they if they can keep
us in a um
a state of uh I don't know how do I how
I print how I even say it like of not
knowing what is that called like a state
of curiosity so basically they yeah it's
it's a form of suspense but it's just
like I want to know what's going on and
I'm still curious and I've given you my
attention but I have no [__] clue
what's going on and usually movies can
do it for like maybe five years yeah
that's true maybe a movie does it for
like 15 minutes or 20 minutes and you're
like why am I still watching this but I
need to know what's gonna [__] happen
this show has kept you pretty much for
the whole first episode which an hour
and 20 minutes you don't exactly know
what's going on you don't know how it's
transferred you know that it's taken
over Society you know this guy wants to
go find his brother you don't know how
really Society works you don't really
know anything but you're kind of locked
in so the logic is sound but all the
information gaps are interesting exactly
yeah and um yeah just HBO [__] nobody
else needs to make TV
did you like walking dead
for Four Seasons it was like you had to
watch the reason I got [__] up on is I
Saw The Walking Dead auditions did you
ever see this video now you can't go
back literally it [__] my brain up
where I've watched that just like a clip
on like Instagram it's like oh Walking
Dead walker auditions and bro it's the
cringiest [__] [__] in the world and
I've watched it and I was like I can't
it's like the whole show I got the ick
for the show oh because they were
pretending to be zombies or whatever
have you ever seen this this is the
cringiest I like I cannot believe this
is what aspiring actors want to do they
they all walk in this room
and this is like their dream they're
like finally I'm gonna make it and then
it just shows
I'll just like walking around the fire
though like they're committed dude bro
some of these guys are [__] killing
it gray shirt with the with the blue
jeans crushing yeah you know what you
gotta do and someone has to cast this no
hold on hold on hold on you gotta edit
in one of those
um uh finding your backup dancer
auditions you know what I mean like
Chris Brown like you cut in Chris Brown
going okay I'm searching for my back
dancers backup dancers I gotta do this
and then cutting in with a bunch of
white people trying to be zombies bro it
just like it freaked me out and then
they do solos where you got to go in
front of everyone
yeah we don't have the audio for some
reason but like they're all grunting and
[__] I don't want to see this and I
watched this and I was like I'm done
okay I don't want to hear I don't
believe in it
this is the grossest [__] in the world
also you think Down syndrome zombies are
the same
yeah because it's more about the host
not the host it's more about the fungi
so it's the same so it's just a vessel
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah and they might be
stronger to be honest with you do you
think they sound the same
I think they sound more similar to how
they were as humans yeah like are there
vocal cords yeah yeah yeah I was talking
to Chris about this yeah it really made
noise though
yeah that's what kind of what I like
it's not a lot of zombie
foreign
I like to see what humans do when
everything falls apart
because I have my suspicions about
humanity and like how we treat each
other and it's nice to see how people
think we would treat each other if
everything fall apart it's really easy
to be nice to people when you have air
conditioning and heat and a job and
money and yeah you know if you don't
have a job there's welfare and you know
I mean like it's it's nice you could
just sit on the street with a cup and
people put money in it and then you can
use that money to go buy things but like
what happens when none of that exists
and there's not enough food and not
enough water and there's no electricity
and there's nothing left how do we treat
each other we're [__] animals dude
it's back in the animal kingdom yeah you
know as simple as that you're getting
snatched up yeah like that's kind of
cool to see I'm actually surprised you
like it as much as you do because it's
like I feel like Hollywood doesn't like
Taking Chances and this is the epitome
of not taking the chance you have the
exact story already written for you yeah
like yup exactly how to execute it yep
yeah but I don't have a problem with
that in the sense that like most movies
are based on books the good ones they
still but they still have to like adapt
it to movie form like this is literally
just the
the game like it's the game and They're
copying scenes in the game so it's like
it's like I assume a lot of in between
dialogue doing that [__] for the gamers
that's the tricky thing about it it's
like it can't even be if it's influenced
by the game and then it's a completely
different story The Gamers are pissed
yeah like this isn't consistent what the
[__] are you doing so they gotta tie it
to the game and uh then the people then
people can look at and be like wait a
minute you're just copying the game
you're not doing anything you need to
yourself but I would rather that because
it's still bringing it more to life like
it's if you watch the whole thing in the
game you'll be like okay but if you see
Peter Pascal's an amazing actor if you
see him this girl that's really good
yeah the lady Marmot that you're like oh
[__] I'm feeling this way it's nice bro
she's good that I'm not this is a little
bit of a spoiler but it's like 30
minutes in the first episode I was so
sad when the daughter died oh yeah and
this is my my best friend Peter always
wanted to make uh the book I Am Legend
is based on it's actually more about the
scientists what keeps you from just
killing yourself in that situation like
what makes you live what makes you want
to keep living yeah and that's something
I thought about a lot while watching
this is like bro if you lose your
daughter yeah my brother not enough for
me to keep going yeah I mean I already
lost my wife yeah I love my brother yeah
yeah and that's what I I was thought
that the whole show was gonna be about
these two trying to survive and then
when I found out she died I was like God
damn dude yeah I don't even know if I
want to watch the rest it's so [__]
sad awesome choice for a show to make
you fall in love oh she's so sweet and
adorable character yeah that's like Game
of Thrones [__] yeah yes yeah but that's
what they do first episode so like first
episode you meet his daughter and she's
like the ideal daughter and he's kind of
like the shitty dad and I'm sure this
new relationship he's gonna kind of have
a second chance at fatherhood and
there'll be something really interesting
there I imagine you [__] know it all
but uh but it was it was really cool
like you know the girl's gone so you're
watching it like damn how much they
gonna make us like this girl she's
making breakfast for her father for his
whatever it's kind of about her at the
beginning
on her than him yeah and they do that on
purpose and then they snatch you away
for [__] Crush for me dude right so
now you follow around this guy with all
this heartbreak but you almost have to
justify the callousness of him right
like I can see him being a callous
[__] up character yeah if I know what
he's been through yeah but if I don't
know what you've been through you can't
just be an [__] yeah you know so now
when he I imagine removes that callous
with this new person he's protecting
this new girl like you're gonna get to
see the character come to uh you know
come full circle and but who knows maybe
maybe something happens to her too it's
just cool to see HBO be HBO the [__]
ghost guys that clip you just watched
was a part of our patreon now if you
want to watch the full patreon episode
if you want to join the other 20 000
[__] Army members go to patreon.com
flagrant